[Music]
hi guys welcome back to another
challenge video and today we are going
to do the whisper count yeah we're
playing the winter italic today so the
way we play is one of us will be wearing
a head I'm playing some loud music so we
can't hear each other and then the other
person is going to be reading a phrase
up of these tiny little pulses and then
we have to guess what we are
each saying yeah by reading our lips
because we can hear each other you say
stuff to me where dissect and then play
here we go can you hear me what what I
think you pooped your pants wait it is
that I love them
ok here we go you ready this is the
first one that's the sugar Michael
Jackson in Spanish shut up this is good
this is Isaac alright you still love
favorites all the time that's the sugar
yeah I 5 it says that's the sugar
I know it haha ready bro your way your
hair is good - Jabbar yes roses are red
rolling through the forest
this is our a lullaby boots ever look
cute wrong roses are red red rubber and
you're glue
you're a Buddhist blue yeah and the pink
roses are red
violets are blue your hair is blue etter
though I said I get any of it right was
I really close you got roses are red
your hair is blue like one care China
can also does iCal do I get a point
I'll give you half a football I got half
a point thanks buddy
okay your turn Captain Underpants does
Charles Amma a pleasure to have you as a
son that's true why Captain Underpants
so to tralala your favorite movie
oh but no mm-hmm like what Captain
Underpants
I pledge in two places casting our
players and the guy is not oh it's the
season to be jolly good underpin me
please please captain um please
Katz's can't please I don't know - you
look so you couldn't guess well it says
Captain Underpants of tralala you need
to be controllable long enough is that
how it doesn't flatter okay ready
Internet where we're going in Tunis [ __ ]
/ / in in your
[Applause]
you're like turning your tongue okay
suppose we got it
I am get a report internet kids I need
you to make a decision
am i close guys ain't her Oh leave me
please yes Oh even more of a time
because Isaac has a list of sleep with
sleep okay I mean I give up I can't make
up anything that you're saying
so it was Internet kids never school oh
man that was hard I could not make out
anything you were saying you're ready
for your it yeah I like doing the earful
you like nothing okay you ready
yes okay you are on the Hawaiian bread
baguette oh you are the O'Reilly Auto
Parts manager but you you are you are
the Hawaiian what - Hawaiian quick bread
break diet tech oh you are one of the
priceless kid oh you are on the Hawaiian
bread site you wanna walk friends
Hawaiian bread diet oh you are the one
friend he takes the present your face is
so cute
he thinks he's the one present you are
our Hawaiian flank
Oh give me bread break bread bread bread
guidance test a oh you are the bad
Spanish speaker oh you ready to give up
you wanna come down yeah shouldn't be
off
oh you're in you're on the Hawaiian
bread I guess oh this is that why are
you on the line for that because they're
important yeah so recently Internet in
case you to buy a lot of Hawaiian bread
so everyday right for breakfast we're
not for lunch right yeah yeah peanut
butter much skinny NATO butter sandwich
okay your turn so like you are a dick 15
sizes size you are you are a dick see ya
you you are a dude you are
did you are ugly your Korea you are a 52
Stein you are there to die like not even
close up not even biggest me die
I give up hey up let me know how bad was
it how far noise you're addicted to
exactly Oh what you can't think that
human look like DYI terribly looking so
Peter died hey I'm addicted study hard
okay so we did this alliance undress me
no I feel is so alive you'll feel alive
you want explain that one to them so one
day Casey went to my ranch I think yeah
he went he went to the store for like
cubes on like five or ten minutes right
cuz or was around the corner so then
Isaac was like yeah I'll stay home alone
I'll test it out and the hands are
affecting you I feel so alive because I
gaze out okay that's good I secretly I
warmly fart secretly want a baby water
baby sore hi Emily want a big early part
this is the figure same way I secretly
like secretly want a baby baby
we got one you do I want to blow me
stuff here you do I get no I just only
boy stuff I know we all might girl here
and I'll get another girl Amy is getting
really yeah
I know you're bored I just want to be
annoying you want to be annoyed by
adventures I'm so sorry my child oh
you're so big okay so is really sweet
it's only storks lived Oh what is miter
saw Pikachu I choose you come true
you could you be cool true I choose you
I can truth did you enter you this SEO
Pikachu I choose you oh yeah I pick my
nose is you Pichu sang it alone oh
you're close and I was saying Pikachu I
choose you because I didn't spin into
Pokemon yeah yeah you thought it was
going to be up yeah yeah so once I take
you up to me and Casey were huddled us
all up together
he's like hey guys let's have a party we
had a little tiny making 40 minutes
middle of club kárma what Halley's Comet
party yeah
[Applause]
let's have a party the time difference
when me and Cameron like yeah yeah yeah
so I'm having a good read good all
together I don't know we didn't keep a
wig in English yeah I'm sorry but it's
okay scores don't matter it's all about
having fun right yeah did you know yes I
have a blast
watchu all right guys thanks for
watching our whisper challenge with me
Isaac
let us know in the comments below there
any other challenges you would like to
see us do right yes oh come come back
come back we need you for the afro we're
doing the conclusion is conclusion to
the video oh good the Cucaracha
Cucaracha all right guys like using his
own little world
I like this video please subscribe down
below yeah and even any comments if you
want just only if they want issue we can
do all we can do the wasabi challenge
how many how much no no why would you
say you want to do it without a sudden
being Casey let's do it right now I feel
you're gonna do it by
okay